you
welcome back please
it's a Steven Levy again and I had a
longer introduction plan but were
pressed for time so but I don't think
our guest needs much of an introduction
he's vinton cerf one of the founding
fathers of the Internet inventor
co-designer of the eye of the tcp/ip
protocols he is currently the vice
president and chief internet evangelist
at Google he's coming to us via Skype
it's worth a billion dollars to
Microsoft to get him on here please
welcome Vint Cerf there he is can you
hear me all right hi i've been how are
you well i'm sitting out in Los Angeles
so I'm sorry that I couldn't be there in
person with you so this all I have to do
okay well we're delighted to have you
there first one question before we start
looking forward you were there at the
beginning there knowing then what you
know now let's say if you know then what
you know now would you and your fellow
designers of the architectural you not
done anything differently well let's see
first of all it's one thing to know that
you should have done something
differently it's something else to know
whether you could have done it
differently so I'll tell you what I
would have done if I could one of them
would have been to choose a much larger
address space so we wouldn't have to go
through this ipv4 to ipv6 introduction
which is painful but happening as you
know Nate we did a worldwide ipv6 days
said but it would be nice not to have to
do that and second I put would have
built more into the system for security
and authenticity of dedication of users
authentication of the devices in the net
but the technology to do that wasn't
developed until after we hit
standardized the 1978 versions of the
protocols which is largely what you're
using today do you think that now we
have the tools to provide that the
security that we're striving to achieve
their we just had a little discussion
about this on stage few minutes ago so
the answer is yes I do I don't think
that we necessarily can do everything
that we want but we can do a great deal
more than we have in the past we can do
good strong authentication we can use
two-factor than
asian we can check for false IP
addresses as they enter into the network
we can secure the domain name system we
can secure the routing system by using
rpki there are a whole series of things
that we could do now with available
technology but it takes agreement for
people to do that and on top of this the
Steve there's more than just technology
we have to come to some common
agreements on an international basis
about what for example does a digital
signature mean what legal weight does it
have what do we do about malfeasance on
the network doobly have recourse when an
attackers in one country and the victim
is in another that's going to change
some multilateral agreements on the
legal side and which are not yet in
place so what you mentioned a few
challenges there which one do you think
is are the biggest threat to the net as
we see it now I think probably the
biggest threats have to do with the
introduction of you know worms and
viruses Trojan horses and things of that
sort you know direct attacks subtle
attacks the spear fishing for example
which catches people unawares because in
some ways they are overly naive about
the email that they receive things like
that now we can attack those problems
for example by using strongly
authenticated origin so we could verify
word is an email come from you can
refuse to interact with the party unless
you have a strong indication that the
party is who they say they are so there
are things along those lines that I
think are the toughest to deal with to
say nothing of coming to multilateral
agreements about law enforcement in
which all parties are treated yet both
fairly but effectively mm-hmm so let's
talk about Kansas City for a minute
google has this project going on there
they wanted to select the community in
the United States to provide ultra high
speed broadband in a reasonable price
that correct they chose Kansas City
Kansas now they're going to do it in
Missouri as well there what's what's the
point of that is this is a proof of
concept does Google want to get into the
internet provider business
so first of all my element in hula Santa
long history with both the internet and
with the cable communications and the
like is leading that project our purpose
is not to get into this as a business
sesa Sara Lee it's to both demonstrate
what happens when you have gigabit
speeds available some pretty dramatic
applications are possible that would be
less attractive at lower data rates but
second in order to verify and to
illustrate what the actual costs are for
implementing and operating systems of
this kind now it's my hope and
expectation that we will share what we
learned with others ultimately I would
imagine that this network will be
remanded to another party for operations
but I don't know that for certain mm-hmm
what what kinds of innovations do you
expect to see arising from well what one
very obvious thing is that when you're
dealing with video and of course we deal
with a lot of it through YouTube that
when you're watching video today's
streaming is a very common practice when
you're operating in bit speeds you can
actually deliver a video file faster
than you can watch it and so rather than
pushing the bits out in a synchronous
way that is to say so that speech and
video are carefully synchronized and
that the video and audio don't break up
because you deliver packets at exactly
the right time instead you could
literally download the the hours worth
of video in about 15 seconds and then
watch it at your leisure so it actually
puts less stress on the network to have
the higher speed of operation after that
who knows their people invariably find
new ways of using capacity that you
never thought of once you supply it so I
know you've been a strong advocate of
net neutrality in you know your role
Google you explain us where we are now
in light of you know the FCC's the
decision to go with it in a way that
seems to you know have something that
displeased everyone almost you know but
give give something than that net
neutrality and where Google is in light
of its of agreement with the rise and to
sort of separate out the definition of
net neutrality between the mobile
world and the landline world so let me
start out by saying that the FCC as you
know has postulated to set of neutrality
mechanisms and we hope that they'll be
able to enforce that but as you can see
from one court case there may need to be
legislation to give them additional
leverage second with regard to the
proposal that came from google and
verizon this was really a homework
assignment the question was given to
parties who were very far apart how far
could they how close did they get in
terms of any kind of recommendation the
purpose behind that document was to
inject ideas into a legislative process
it was not a an agreement between google
and verizon that was not a deal it was
simply text to be considered in a
legislative process the fact is that we
couldn't come to an agreement about what
to do about wireless and since we
to do we didn't say anything in their
particular document I think many people
believe that we should see these as all
common assets and that we should be
equally neutral about their ability our
ability to access those assets but I
think it's still fair to say that there
is less capacity in the highly
contentious wireless environment and
therefore one has to be more thoughtful
about its management but beyond that I
hope that there will be avail access to
broadband in all of its forms wired and
wireless will be equally accessible to
everyone I use the term equal with some
care here we understand that some people
have more capacity because they paid for
more some people will have less that we
don't object to we understand the need
for network management we simply don't
want the access to the broadband
channels whether wired or wireless to be
used in an anti-competitive way and I
think that's the intent of the FCC
language that's certainly our hope as
well so I want you to explain a term
I've heard attributed to you the
interplanetary internet what what is
that what does it mean and when will we
have it at this I was waiting for you to
say n are you out of your gourd
so this was actually a project started
at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory in 1998
we said you know up till now up to them
most of the communications for Space
Exploration had been accomplished with
point-to-point radio links and we
thought what would happen if we had a
rich networking environment in which to
support both manned and robotic
exploration so we took off and said well
what would it take to build an
interplanetary internet and in the end
we discovered that we couldn't use the
standard tcp/ip protocols because the
round trip times are too big you know
flow control with TCP or the 40-minute
round-trip time just doesn't work so we
had to invent a whole new suite of
protocols that we call delay and
disruption tolerant networking that
deals with the long delays and also with
the disruption caused by planetary
motion we've implemented the protocols
there on board the space station there
on board an epoxy spacecraft that just
the rendezvous with a comet Hartley 2 in
November last year we're standardizing
the protocols with the consultative
committee on space data systems and
we're hoping now that these protocols
will be adopted by all the spacefaring
nations so that all of our spacecraft
will be able to communicate with each
other in a standard way just like when
you plug your computer into the internet
you can talk to a billion or so other
machines because of the standards so
we're actually quite far along in terms
of the technical capability to operate
networks in space Wow so we have the
interplanetary internet that's awesome
oh one one one final question that you
mentioned ipv6 you know I think at those
tests we had were positives or are we
now on a collision course with the
Internet of Things that well I don't
know if I would call it a collision
course I've been quite excited with the
idea a nice commercial lots and lots of
appliances on the network means that
they can be managed through that network
and it means opportunities for third
parties for example if you put all of
your entertainment equipment on the net
suitably access control of course and
then you turn over the responsibility
for managing all of your entertainment
to a third party you could just go to a
nice of a web page and say I want these
movies and this music put this on the
ipod put this in the car put this on the
DVR at home and you know
these other things on my laptop all of
that stuff could be managed now my house
is fully wired for sensor networks using
ipv6 in a wireless mode and they're
reporting the state of the house every
five minutes to a server downstairs and
every twice a day I get a summary report
of how things are doing in the wine
cellar so the fact is that we're going
to see lots and lots of these sorts of
automated appliances and houses that are
fully sensor network becoming a part of
the normal environment and I'm quite
excited about what you can do with that
great well then I know we can go on for
a long time but you you have to have to
run here we rolled a Tribeca are very
happy that you're on our planet thank
you so much for sharing sometimes thanks
so much bye bye see baby come on